sur cette route qui serpente au milieu
de la forêt tropicale camerounaise
un patron par inspecter un de ses
chantiers monsieur ping est un des
pionniers de la présence chinoise en
afrique
quinze ans qu'il sillonne le continent
pour le patron chinois
il n'est pas tous les jours facile de
diriger des centaines d'employés
cameroun est arrivée dans ce village
monsieur pong s'inquiètent les ouvriers
creusent pour lui une tranchée pour
installer la fibre optique dans tout le
pays
navire à peine débarqué de voiture le
patron chinois doit faire face à une
rébellion
on n'a pas parlé à m on veut un maître
statut de la main vers la fin et en mon
nom
on se bat on ne mange pas selon les
ouvriers
la terre est trop dure il existe une
prime ils sont comme ça je dois régler
ce genre de problème tous les jours je
sais bien que c'est dur de travailler en
plein soleil sur un chantier monsieur
ping ne se laisse pas intimider
il leur fait la démonstration qu'il est
tout à fait possible de creuser
reste maintenant à négocier pas évident
car monsieur pong parle une langue bien
à lui
un cocktail d'anglais de français le
tout avec l'accent chinois
rhodia par prendre leur temps d'essayer
la crainte c'est dû à des réductions
monsieur pong et c'est de leur dire
qu'il n'a pas l'intention de céder quand
les ouvriers camerounais le comprennent
le ton monte ça va là c'est petit à
petit mais travaille beaucoup les
occupants à des rationnements pas des
rationnements régaler car tu vois
monsieur ping bat en retraite
tu vois ça pas d'état spa de bordeaux
lac
charest avait lé pa bouche tu vois c'est
bien maintenant tu as vu ça c'est lui
qui m'a donné sa as à la pomme de moyen
terme à ses marges et maintenant la rue
mayet yoga your mother was et y avait
combien mis dans un fauteuil au talon il
est allé dans le sens dimanche à sa 108e
mère fauteuil à 335,6 ne peut pas louper
bien on m'a d'abord le tollé le coût
d'un point et vont l'arrêter chez eux
aux bienfaits allez on y va
la situation est bloquée et risquent de
dégénérer
monsieur ping doit lâcher du lest une
rallonge de 15 centimes par mètre
creuser des négociations permanentes
auxquelles monsieur ping est habitué je
suis calme parce que je vois ça tous les
jours
je suis habitué à chaque fois ils se
plaignent mais si c'était aussi dur il
ne reviendrait pas travailler des
patrons chinois aux prises avec des
ouvriers au coeur de la brousse en
afrique
la scène est désormais banal
des routes des hôpitaux des stades
depuis 15 ans les constructions chinoise
poussent comme des champignons des
centaines de chant qui est financé par
pékin dans le cadre d'une vaste
opération séduction sur tout le
continent
en échange les dirigeants chinois
viennent demander pétrole minerais et
autres matières premières dont la chine
a besoin pour son économie
sénégal congo côte d'ivoire un
débarquement irrésistible même dans les
pays de l'afrique francophone
au cameroun les chinois seraient
désormais près de 30000 cinq fois plus
que les anciens maîtres des lieux
aucun domaine de leur échappe
[Musique]
en quelques années ces nouveaux
conquérants ont fait main basse sur le
petit commerce
monsieur yan possède ainsi 15 boutiques
à douala avec sa famille il ya aussi des
bâtisseurs envoyés par pékin
c'est le cas de monsieur jean pierre de
son oeuvre alors vous le trouvez comment
notre stade
c'est mieux que ce que font les français
en ont une présence qui inquiète les
commerçants comme victoire aux siens
ceux qui viennent après y'a plus classe
non mais aussi les manutentionnaires
employés par les patrons chinois he une
forme de colonisation
une implantation qui génère des trafics
comme celui de l'ivoire
[Musique]
mais pour une nouvelle génération de
camerounais l'avenir s'écrit temps
mandarins de la france a fait à la chine
a fait plonger dans le cameroun des
chinois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
douala la capitale économique du
cameroun
dès 8 heures du matin une foule de
petits revendeurs attend avec impatience
l'ouverture de la meilleure adresse de
la ville dès que les grilles se lève
c'est la ruée à l'intérieur des
chaussures mais aussi des pantalons de
la maroquinerie tout pour habiller les
camerounais à bas prix signe particulier
la plupart des vendeurs sont chinois
en pièce est à présent 5 à 1 euro 20 au
prix de gros revendus 3 euros sur les
marchés du pays
les détaillants se bousculent c'est quoi
ta bouche à toi c'est pour marc vendre
vous même vous êtes marque commerçants
et c'est comme ça tous les jours des
dizaines de mètres cubes de marchandise
quittent le magasin
le patron c'est monsieur yan 34 ans
originaire du sud de la chine il a tout
quitté pour venir faire fortune ici
comment ça va les affaires aujourd'hui
tout est à vous ici oui dans cette
galerie tous les magasins que vous voyez
sont à moi vous avez mis combien de
temps j'ai commencé en 2003 sept ans
pour bâtir son succès entourés de
parents et d'amis immigrés comme lui au
cameroun il y à ses deux frères est
aussi madame li sa belle soeur en tout
nous avons une quinzaine de magasins et
ça représente combien de personnes dans
chaque boutique
il y a deux à trois personnes une petite
entreprise de 45 personnes chinois et
camerounais qui travaillent ensemble
[Musique]
sa marchandise monsieur yens l'achète au
prix usine en chine
il a fait venir directement par
containers entiers aucun grossistes
camerounais n'est capable de lui faire
concurrence comme monsieur yens des
dizaines d'autres commerçants chinois se
sont installés dans ce quartier au cours
des cinq dernières années c'est devenu
le plus grand chinatown d'afrique
centrale avec ses magasins ses
restaurants son hôtel 2 étoiles et même
sa clinique traditionnelle chinoise
cette clinique c'est le dernier
investissement de monsieur yen à sa tête
il a placé un de ses cousins qui l'a
fait venir du pays
le docteur fang 29 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la clinique n'attirent plus
seulement les chinois le 7 juin
c'est pas pris mon pied pour ça
ça me
ça va avant ça c'est pas vraiment ça
sera non ici aussi la communication est
difficile c'est pas comme ça
les camerounais affluent car en afrique
le médecin traditionnel chinois est
presque considéré comme un magicien
c'est un ami qui m'a informée qui un
médecin chinois à voir qui près j'aurais
bien et qu'il avait eu de même un
problème ils tentent aussi de cibler des
citoyens d'où le faible et sexuelle tic
tic tic tic tic
bon
le docteur fink facture 7h50 la
consultation
quatre mois après son arrivée il gagne
déjà trois fois plus que son salaire à
l'hôpital public en chine mais il ya un
revers à la médaille
ça c'est une photo de ma famille qu'on a
prises en chine à l'aéroport juste avant
de partir je m'en veux d'être partie
sans eux vous pensez avait à ce moment
c'est vraiment triste
oui
moi
ça ne regrettait pas d'avoir fait venir
votre cousin nous n'avons pas d'autre
choix
tout le monde ne réagit pas de la même
manière ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'argent ne tombe pas du ciel comme ça
sans faire d'effort moi aussi j'ai deux
enfants en chine
ils font leurs études là-bas mon but
c'est de gagner beaucoup d'argent
je veux pouvoir en envoyer en chine à
mes parents à mes enfants pour qu'ils
vivent bien
c'est pour ça qu'on est là sinon ne
partirai pas aussi loin
ces dernières semaines monsieur yan a
fait venir cinq nouveaux chinois douala
tous de la même province que lui à
chaque fois il règle toutes les
formalités
te voilà un récépissé son titre de
séjour lui sera délivré après cela durée
de validité ces deux mois le prix c'est
entre 300 et 500 euros
à leur arrivée monsieur yan trouve à ses
nouvelles recrues un logement et leur
fait découvrir les secrets du chinatown
de douala ce midi il les emmène au
restaurant pad enseigne juste une entrée
d'immeuble ordinaire c'est une cantine
clandestine
inconnu du fisc camerounais en haut des
marches pour franchir les grilles il
faut être accompagné
dr faye nous sert de laissez-passer
goombas sauter à la citronnelle boeuf au
poivre de sechuan tout est cuisiné aux
épices chinoise importés dans les
conteneurs de chaussures de textile
[Musique]
ces nouveaux immigrants sont arrivés
avec quelques centaines d'euros
empochent leur objectif se lancer dans
le commerce de gros
comme monsieur jan il ne nous reste plus
qu'à trouver une boutique quand on aura
le magasin je suis sûr que ça va marcher
bien sûr en cas de problème je serai là
pour les aider ils peuvent compter sur
moi une communauté solidaire qui profite
à plein de la percée politique de la
chine en afrique
en plein coeur de yaoundé la capitale
tron le symbole de cette présence
chinoise le palais omnisports
[Musique]
ce bâtiment à l'architecturé
spectaculaire c'est monsieur yin qu'il a
construit un ouvrage sorti de terre en
deux ans grâce à 300 ouvriers venus de
chine
la compétition sportive cérémonie à
chaque événement monsieur linh vient
s'assurer que tout fonctionne ça là vous
allez me le démontrer le palais des
sports se veut une vitrine futuriste du
savoir faire chinois
vous voyez la forme de ce stade il est
en rond l'idée dans l'appel d'offres
était de faire penser à une soucoupe
volante porteuse de l'amitié de la chine
craint de tous ils ont aimé ce concept
chinois que nous leur proposions sur le
gouvernement chinois a financé les 20
millions d'euros de la construction du
stade car il fait partie de la stratégie
de pékin pour asseoir son influence en
afrique sera monsieur linh d'ailleurs
travaille pour une entreprise d'état
depuis sept ans il dirige des projets
sur tout le continent
à deux pas du stade dans ses bureaux les
photos de ses plus belles réalisations
suffisait sera en afrique nous avons
réalisé entre 20 et 30 projets
centrafrique erythrée il y à un bénin
niger
nous sommes très nombreux
notre groupe compte plus de trente mille
personnes des chantiers de prestige
inauguré à chaque fois par deux hautes
personnalités chinoises
ça c'est en 2007 pendant l'inspection du
chantier par le président hu jintao
le ministre des sports ici notre pdg et
ça c'est le jour de l'inauguration du
palais omnisports par le président paul
biya à yaoundé monsieur dean vite ici
dans ce campement aux allures de
casernes à ses côtés vivre avec lui ses
contremaîtres et ses techniciens une vie
d'expatrié qui n'a rien de luxueux
attendez une seconde le lit n'est pas
fait
bienvenue chez monsieur guînes une
théière une clim hors d'âge pas de télé
juste une calligraphie au mur ça c'est
une calligraphie chinoise très ancienne
c'est l'histoire de deux hommes à cheval
c'est une histoire très nostalgique
le patron c'est recréer son petit coin
de chine pour les grandes occasions il a
même la tenue traditionnelle le tangue
en chinois
un proverbe dit qu'il faut vivre les
difficultés ensemble pour motiver les
gens tu habites dans une villa tu n'es
plus dans le bon esprit chinois disent
nous sommes tous égaux des chinois qui
s'entassent dans des campements
[Musique]
bien loin de la vie dorée que mènent les
occidentaux au cameroun le dimanche ces
rendez vous au club de golf sur les
hauteurs de yaoundé ou bien au club
hippique en contrebas un des lieux les
plus prisés des français du cameroun lé
croissant dont gérard importe en afrique
de l'outillage made in france
il est l'un des piliers de cette
communauté de privilégier une grosse
semaine de travail
effectivement mais bien se retrouver ici
onze ans que j'ai eu le président que le
betis
32 ans jean damy bonjour aujourd'hui au
club se tient la compétition annuelle de
saut d'obstacles merci encore d'être
venu on va commencer plus course à
l'américaine
et si les moniteurs voulait faire entrer
leurs cavaliers nombreux palefrenier
cadre agréable et ambiance country club
la vie facile pour ces enfants
d'expatriés français qui pour la plupart
possèdent leur propre monture
mais malgré les apparences ce sont là
les vestiges d'une époque révolue
j'en lis bose en a bien conscience
il est retraité de l'industrie du bois
un secteur qui comme le petit commerce
ou les grands travaux tombe aujourd'hui
aux mains des chinois
[Musique]
quand il est arrivé au cameroun il y à
34 ans dix sept mille français vivaient
encore dans le pays contre 6300
seulement aujourd'hui avec gérard le
président du club hippique il a vécu le
temps béni de la suprématie incontestée
de la france le monopole france
on appelle ça le pré carré et
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez appris avec les
chinois on peut dire malgré tout ma
logique on n'a pas comblé les chinois
ils sont là ils viennent s'implanter et
faire ce que nous ne faisons pas donc à
nous de prendre place à nous de rester
en place et d'être peut-être plus
agressif dans les apôtres aucun chinois
n'est membre du club hippique
pourtant le dimanche à l'heure de
l'apéro le match france chine est dans
toutes les têtes je pense qu'on peut pas
de comparer les deux communautés
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
différent la façon de lui
oui est-ce qu'ils ont choisie l'an
prochain il y avait deux saucissons
marche sciatique qui étaient là qui est
partie au congo brazzaville
je les ai vus travailler dans le nord
congo
il n'avait pas de choix 7 et 30
personnes dans une pièce avec un sac de
vie c'était visible c'est tout ça des
français résigné avec toutefois un
dernier espoir qu'un jour les chinois
eux aussi s'embourgeoise 10 15 ans ils
ont frappé notre nouveau né qui
fonctionneront la même manière que nous
aujourd'hui exigeant c'est quasi sûr que
là et c'est un peu une vie de forçat
convoi nous qu'on a vu oui c'est pas
c'est pas comme nous il n'a pas dû clore
sa enfin quand on nous voit dimanche à
sion la semaine
alors ça
je crois qu'il est français le champagne
[Musique]
l'angola l'un des concurrents chinois
les plus redoutables pour les français
c'est monsieur ping le patron aux prises
avec ses ouvriers camerounais c'est la
tranchée pour enfouir la fibre optique
nous n'en sommes qu'au début en tout
elle fera plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de la frontière gabonaise
jusqu'à yaoundé sur son chantier
monsieur ping est obligé de faire
travailler chinois et camerounais
ensemble
regardez le lui c'est notre chef
d'equipe technique
regardez son bronzage c'est sale
ouvriers chinois ils travaillent sur le
terrain et il est là pour surveiller le
crabe ou un chef d'equipe pas vraiment
satisfait des rendements de sa main
d'oeuvre locale
nous les chinois en travaillant 16
heures par jour on pourrait progresser
de 2 km tous les jours avec eux on
progresse à peine de quelques centaines
de mètres
ce marché de 60 millions d'euros
monsieur ping l'a remporté au nez à la
barbe des français qui il ya encore peu
de temps lui barrait la route
il ne voulait pas de nous eux ils se la
couler douce
il prenait tout des bénéfices sans rien
faire imaginez un gâteau il est là pour
tout le monde
eh bien ces entreprises françaises qui
étaient là depuis longtemps ne voulais
pas le partage
[Musique]
à cause de ces chantiers monsieur ping
passe sa vie sur les routes du cameroun
ce soir il dort dans un de ces camps de
base un petit hôtel près de la frontière
gabonaise monsieur ping et son équipe
occupe la moitié des chambres de
l'établissement
l'hôtel dispose un restaurant mais les
ouvriers de monsieur pingon obtenu de
faire cuisine à part en moyenne ils
restent ici deux ans pour faire passer
le temps ils se concocte des petits
plats bien de chez eux
est ce que vous regrettez est revenu non
je ne regrette rien on sait bien que la
vie à l'étranger c'est difficile en plus
ici il ya vraiment vraiment trop de
moustiques ici leur salaire est deux
fois plus élevé qu'en chine en
entreprise nous garantit qu'on gagnera
au minimum 1000 euros par an une
expédition qui n'est pas sans risque au
cameroun certains y laissent leur santé
ce soir dans l'équipe il y à un malade
monsieur ping part s'assurer qu'il va
mieux
lui il vient à peine d'arriver et il est
déjà tombé malade il a attrapé le palu
et la malaria
il ya trop de moustiques ici on la
trappe facilement
ça va tu as encore de la fièvre
j'ai bien pris des médicaments j'ai de
la fièvre on t'a fait à piqûre ça va
aller à main je serai bien bon bah sinon
tu vas aller te faire faire une piqûre à
yaoundé bon allez repose toi bien salut
monsieur tong sait s'y prendre avec ses
ouvriers chinois avec les camerounais
c'est une autre affaire ce matin son
équipe doit réparer une canalisation
demander aux gens de mettre tout ça sur
le camion est pas celui là il est cassé
mais les ouvriers ne semble pas disposer
à obtempérer
en cause encore une fois les salaires
donc il va chercher le camion s'il te
plaît ils réclament 7 euros par jour 2
de plus que ce que propose monsieur ping
le patron risque le blocage mais cette
fois il est bien décidé à ne pas céder
depuis le début c'est 500 c'est le
salaire qu'on a fixés avec tout le monde
ce travail là il va durer un jour ou
deux alors maintenant vous faites ce que
vous voulez c'est ça ce soir et bien
prenez le camion est parti
excédé monsieur ping quitte les
négociations
c'est alors un bras de fer qui s'engage
devant l'autel d'un côté les grévistes
écoutent de la musique pour tuer le
temps de l'autre sur la terrasse
monsieur pong boit un thé et joue la
montre en mal de pollen des arbres à
giovanni père reigns
si j'accepte qu'une fois leur demande
ils viendront réclamer tous les jours
alors là je m'en sortirais pas
et pour le même travail en chine
j'aurais pu y moins de problèmes au cou
mois
finalement certains acceptent de
repartir sur le chantier mais d'autres
refusent et jure de ne jamais plus
retravailler avec des chinois
depuis l'arrivée de la fibre optique
amour je travaille la fibre optique mais
j'ai travaillé le patronat camerounais
je n'ai jamais eu ce problème que j'ai
c'est le terreau je doive les chinois
tout pour lui c'est le travail est
malade c'est ton problème c'est fun
c'est ton problème tu vas dormir dehors
c'est ton problème pour vous donne un
poids de vous pouvez connecter bien fait
son travail ne voulons plus nous les
jeunes car monnaies travers la fibre to
come on come stay de l' esclavage
nous voulons être et bien traités mais
ne le permet pas et me + lomb français
bien d'autres assez bien en français
conclure hâtivement par le français
thales
les camerounais ont parfois du mal à se
faire aux pratiques chinoises et pas
seulement sur les chantiers en brousse
à douala aussi la révolte gronde à moins
d'un kilomètre de chinatown le marché
central le grand marché couvert de la
ville où les camerounais viennent
s'approvisionner en tissus vêtements ou
cosmétiques
ici les vendeurs sont encore camerounais
mais l'invasion chinoise est en cours
sauf chez victoire qui a déclaré la
guerre aux chaussures made in china
[Rires]
ces chaussures chinoises
elle interdit même à ses clientes
d'emporter dans son magasin marché
victoire ne vend que des chaussures
françaises
le problème c'est que ces prix sont six
fois plus élevé de 5 euros qui vient de
chier on peut en trouver mais venant de
la france on peut pas avoir chaud sur à
moins de 30 euros
et ça c'est le minimum à victoire craint
de ne pouvoir résister bien longtemps
car progressivement les commerçants
chinois grignote du terrain
dacca
[Musique]
les asiatiques sont là ça recommence à
partir d'ici
à manta les chinois s'installent même
tout autour du marché ou victoire à son
magasin elle a l'impression d'être cerné
marché les premières sont solidaires on
ne veut pas qu'ils entrent dans le
marché oui à 50 izarry tête par lise
envahissent sont dans le sahara qui sont
dans les têtes c'est tout ce qu'elle ait
tous ménagés place de cuisiner tout et
voilà la bac
ces parias de la 3.3 l'a10 après il y
aura des places pour nous c'est tout
aussi la mesure qui viennent après a
plus place le nom
les camerounais commencent à se sentir
envahi et les relations se tendent entre
les deux communautés
ce matin monsieur yann le commerçant de
chinatown est de mauvaise humeur
il vient de s'apercevoir que dans la
nuit on lui a coupé l'alimentation d'eau
de sa clinique
en bas le tuyau de monsieur yan a été
carrément sectionné notre compteur d'eau
était au bout de ce tuyau monsieur yann
ne comprend pas il est en règle
il soupçonne en fait la propriétaire
camerounaise qui lui loue la clinique
d'être à l'origine du forfait quelques
secondes plus tard dans la cour le
commerçant tombe sur elle et lui demande
des explications
sans complexe elle reconnaît avoir
enlevé le compteur et exige 75 euros
pour le lui rendre
monsieur yen est fatigué c'est du
chantage
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on loue ici
tous les mois ils essaient de nous
extorquer de l'argent sont tous les
prétextes
finalement la propriétaire n'aura pas un
centime
mais monsieur yan devra faire intervenir
la compagnie pour obtenir un nouveau
compteur à douala
certains camerounais tente de profiter
de la présence chinoise mais d'une autre
manière
victorine est une ancienne exploitante
forestière reconverti dans la médecine
traditionnelle avec un certain succès si
son cabinet ne désemplit pas c'est parce
que victorine surf sur la mode chinoise
à côté des potions traditionnelle
africaine une armoire à pharmacie plein
de produits chinois chinois aussi font
dans le naturel et colosses que je
prends les produits associés dans
l'afrique c'est rapide
une bithérapie sino camerounaise à la
victorine mais aussi cette petite
mallette magique pour impressionner les
patients un appareil de diagnostic
ces chinois et chinois la petite musique
c'est juste pour rassurer les patients
cette commerçante du quartier est déjà
venu plusieurs fois consultés victorine
ici c'est le système digestif
[Musique]
si le corps est malade il réagit aux
impulsions électriques du stylet ici
c'est le manque d'aération
elle à l'éprouvant à la colombe et et
brassac hollandais témoin me fais
tellement donné caleçon manque de
calcium mais le plus grave est encore à
venir et cruel à l'axé fouillis dans le
corps la patiente seraient atteintes de
fièvre typhoïde
une maladie qui peut être mortelle
immédiatement victorine prescrit un
mélange de remède en vente dans la pièce
d'à côté
le prix mais tous et dissémine s'est
elle est disponible et pas acheter à la
france n' à la ddas 25 euros le premier
traitement trop cher pour cette
commerçante sa typhoïde attendra c'est
dans
cette fois la mallette à diagnostic se
transforme en machine à acupuncture
électrique
cette patiente est en partie paralysé
depuis un accident vasculaire cérébral
elle est prête à supporter les décharges
de plusieurs volts de la machine de
victorine
cette étude la tenture la régie a
recommencé à 110 celui ci contre c'est
peut-être tout va déjà bien il faut que
ça fasse mal
oui c'est bon si ça y quand sa femme
assez intense et rêver ça vous rassure
que ça vous fait mal
mais puisque le pied aussi a fait mal
avant de guérir grille au départ
victorine pratiquait l'acupuncture
traditionnelle celle avec les longue
aiguille fine qu'on enfonce dans le
corps l'acupuncture à la portée de tous
plutôt incertain comme méthode
l'acupuncture je ne connaissais que les
aiguilles qui rentre dans la peau ça
c'est une acupuncture électrique oui
j'ai appelé ses clientes dans la peau
mais je ne veux pas appliquée s'agit
vous expliquer parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de maladies des os et tu peux prendre
les guides ainsi des airs pour
travailler ce qu'elle dit n'est pas si
pire dans ce circuit appliquer plus
d'aiguilhe pour victorine pour cause
d'hygiène pas de problème ces patients
sont contentes souffrir à l'acupuncture
électrique
[Musique]
dans le sillage des chinois d'afrique on
trouve des charlatans mais aussi des
trafiquants
le port de douala est l'une des plaques
tournantes du commerce avec la chine et
il n'y a pas que des marchandises
légales qui y circulent en 2007
les douaniers découvrent dans le double
fond de ce conteneur 3 tonnes d'ivoire
les défenses de 300 éléphants et
éléphanteaux
ce commerce est proscrit dans le monde
entier pourtant la demande chinoise
reste forte et alimente le trafic à
douala
on trouve même des adresse discrète pour
ceux qui veulent s'en procurer sans se
faire remarquer dans un quartier
résidentiel de la ville
voici une de ses adresses
je suis arrivé de lyon dès ce matin
équipé d'une caméra cachée
notre journaliste chinoise se fait
passer pour une commerçante venue de
pékin
achetez des sculptures africaines
derrière ce portail gris un couple de
chinois hébergent leurs compatriotes de
passage
les chambres sont à 25 euros la nuit
elle c'est la fille avec qui tu va
partager la chambre elle est dans le
commerce du bois
cela fait des mois qu'elle est là chez
nous il n'ya pas d'étrangers que des
chinois au rez-de-chaussée le garage
sert de salon et de salle à manger
jessica notre journaliste dévoile enfin
aux propriétaires le but de sa visite
combien d'ivoire je peux rapporter quoi
combien d'ivoire au maximum que je
passais à la douane a absolument rien
c'est totalement interdit
mais il ya des gens qui en achètent
jusqu'à 60 kg après avec la douane c'est
à tes risques et périls
l'aubergiste joue l'étonnement
visiblement sur ses gardes
le lendemain toutefois il accepte de
nous servir de guide et de toute
évidence il en sait long sur le trafic
à deux pas de chinatown notre aubergiste
nous emmène dans un atelier qui ne vend
officiellement que des sculptures en
voix
à peine at il franchi la porte qu'on lui
sort la marchandise interdite notre
guide chinois connaît parfaitement les
prix c'est même lui qui les négocie 12
mois cette famille 3012
dans le deuxième atelier l'ivoire coule
à flot des colliers des statuettes des
bibelots une valise entière de bracelets
mais ce n'est pas tout un revendeur
arrive avec ce sac qu'il gardait caché
dans une remise à l'intérieur une
marchandise rare de l'ivoire brut des
défenses d'éléphants tôt
si j'achète ya pas de police
on ne le sait pas et ne seraient pas
il élude la question mais au cameroun le
trafic de défenses brutes est puni de
trois années de prison
ça tombe bien gros match
de l'album voit ça
la salle bain
trois cent 300 320 soit 100 euros le
kilo la marchandise sera revendue quatre
fois plus cher en chine un trafic très
rentable alimentée par la demande
chinoise
avoir vingt mille éléphants sont ainsi
braconné chaque année en afrique du
trafic d'ivoire des pratiques sociales
contestable monsieur yan connaît la
réputation que traîne les chinois au
cameroun
alors de temps en temps il tente de
corriger le tir ce matin il se rend dans
son entrepôt cette fois c'est pile de
vêtements de chaussures de lessive ne
sont pas destinés à ses magasins mais à
une oeuvre de charité
ils sont pauvres
nous nous gagnons de l'argent c'est
normal de rendre un peu
[Musique]
la marchandise est pour un orphelinat
situé à l'autre bout de la ville
monsieur yan appartient à l'association
chine cameroun une association créée par
des chinois de douala qui organise
régulièrement des distributions à chaque
fois qu'il franchit la porte d'un
orphelinat
le commerçant est ému ses enfants à lui
grandissent en chine
quand je les ai vus j'ai pensé à mes
enfants je suis à l'étranger je ne les
voit presque pas cet après midi une
poignée de commerçants chinois
accompagne le seuil à la retouche à la
pâte on ne sait pas danser
chacun a pris sur son stock pour garnir
la table des parasols des albums photos
des tee-shirts ou encore la lessive de
monsieur jan j'ai enlevé les emballages
pour qu'on voit mieux ce qu'il ya dedans
oui tu as raison on n'a qu'à les mettre
comme ça donner une meilleure image et
chinois en afrique une nécessité car la
plupart d'entre eux envisagent de
s'installer durablement au cameroun
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les chinois
commencent à se mêler timidement aux
autres communautés orange métallique est
une boîte de nuit de douala autrefois
fréquenté par les seuls expatriés
occidentaux
[Musique]
à
ce soir après sept ans passés au
cameroun c'est quasiment une première
pour monsieur yan et son clan ils ont
décidé de s'accorder un moment de
détente entre deux des chargements de
containers on est là pour faire des
affaires donc on ne sort pas beaucoup
d'habitude c'est une occasion très rare
que nous soyons tous réunis comme ça
pour s'amuser ici
m
nous sommes ici pour nous détendre dans
les affaires c'est beaucoup de stress et
c'est le moment on peut se relâcher et
vous venez ici autre chinois ou aussi
avec des camerounais
nous venons plutôt entre copains chinois
moi je rassemble facilement les gens
[Musique]
le whisky coule à flots la boîte de nuit
à l'occidentale et ses danseuses
camerounaise plaisent visiblement
beaucoup à monsieur jan
[Musique]
mais
le patron nicolas un franco-libanais
n'est pas étonné de les voir commencer à
vivre à l'africaine
je commence à les voir dans la vie
nocturne dans mes canards au restaurant
les commandes assorties à venir danser
sur nos musiques aussi tentants d'une
manière ou d'une autre ils rentrent dans
le rang 4 6 dans les petites abouti
rennes aussi déplacé va contre les
français
des chinois qui prennent la place des
français sur les pistes de danse mais
aussi dans le coeur de certains
camerounais car pour la jeune génération
désormais ce sont les chinois qui
représente l'avenir dans les quartiers
populaires de yaoundé la maison de
christelle cet étudiant de 27 ans a une
passion la chine
le chinois et la musique chinoise
qu'elle côtoie la plupart et les
télécharge moi même sur le net
mais bien que vous connaissez comme
celle ci par exemple la chaussée les
parents qui viennent
oui c'est vrai non c'est un car me d'un
chien revient donc s'y incline qui n'y a
ni christelle apprend le chinois depuis
un an et demi et travaille déjà à mi
temps pour une entreprise chinoise
ancienne tuni de jaws
en fait c'est mon papa c'est mon papa
thing de man et d'apprendre le chinois
j'avoue que sur le coup j'ai vraiment
pas compris pourquoi parce que je voyais
vraiment pas l'intérêt
ce n'est que plus tard que j'ai compris
la langue chinois sera dans un futur
proche
dans un futur très proche même une
langue très importante
le chinois christelle l'apprend à
l'institut confucius de yaoundé des
centres comme celui là il y en a déjà
une quinzaine sur le continent africain
un réseau destiné à la diffusion de la
culture chinoise dans le monde
subventionnée par pékin les cours ne
coûte que 15 euros par mois aux
étudiants
quand on pénètre ici plus question de
parler français mais c'est quoi ton nom
chinois déjà j'ai oublié allez dis le
je m'appelle bien aux yeux ça veut dire
jolie jade et moi c'est mouiller ou
jeanne noir et quel est votre prénom
chinois alors du coup chinois oui ça
veut dire quoi petit plus aujourd'hui
c'est le grand concours d'éloquence
annuel 1er prix un voyage d'un mois en
chine
décorum et jury solennelle présidée par
la directrice de l'institut dans le
grand amphithéâtre
ils sont une trentaine à se lancer avec
des histoires de leur choix lysiane
quatre minutes montre en main pour
convaincre
mais attention maîtriser le mandarin
n'est pas donné à tout le monde
[Musique]
entre deux candidats démonstration au
promotion de la culture chinoise autour
de christelle l'an dernier elle avait
remporté le concours cette année elle a
choisi un morceau de la variété chinoise
[Musique]
à la fin de la journée
christelle obtient la meilleure note
[Applaudissements]
grâce à ce concours
la chine a soit chaque jour un peu plus
son influence sur la jeunesse africaine
jusqu alors délivré très facilement des
visas pour aller faire du business en
chine
yaounde le 20 mai dernier le cameroun
commémore son indépendance le maître du
pays le président paul biya a voulu une
fête grandiose pour célébrer les 50 ans
de la rupture avec la france
il a convié des dizaines de chefs d'état
africains des invités du monde entier
dont des ministres français et bien sûr
chinois
[Musique]
le président paul biya fait partie de
ces chefs d'état africains qui ont
ouvert la porte aux chinois il y a dix
ans en leur accordant les premiers
grands contrats mais pour des raisons
diplomatiques pas question de froisser
la france
[Applaudissements]
en fait le président qu'est ce que vous
apporte la chine pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'apporte la chine à la au cameroun
aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'amitié c'est un projet copé m
comme avec la transbaie la chine
impériale un charme
mais ça
la chine n'en lève rien à personne
il n'empêche à l'ambassade de france sur
les hauteurs de yaoundé on s'inquiète ce
soir des ténors de la politique sont
venus de paris pour rassurer les
derniers français du cameroun
tous les jours et vous aurez ce
privilège d'avoir ici au milieu de vous
des personnels est au tour du ministre
de la coopération alain joyandet
michel charasse membre du conseil
constitutionnel et deux anciens premiers
ministres michel rocard et alain juppé
invitation un pince fesses que j'en lis
bose l'un des habitués du club hippique
ne pouvait pas rater
je vais essayer de celui juppé jean
libon espère que cette soirée marquera
le début de la reconquête pour les
français au cameroun gens qui sont venus
ron qui ont créé beaucoup de problèmes
donc pour moi oui c'est un signe un peu
fort c'est la première fois d'ailleurs
que je vois autant de
peut-être couronnais de la france en
même temps ça va
avec 150 millions d'euros d'aidés
directes chaque année la france reste le
premier donateur au cameroun
loin devant pékin le franc comtois
suffisant pourtant à chaque fois qu'il
vient le ministre ne voit que des
drapeaux chinois sur les chantiers au
cameroun
aujourd'hui il est revenu avec un plan
j'exige le drapeau français soit sur les
panneaux de chantier maintenant bien sûr
mais je suis allé visiter cet après midi
grands chantiers financés par par la
france dans un quartier on a
complètement repaver les rues remet de
l'eau potable fait un certain nombre de
choses j'ai vu que ce que j'avais
demandé lors de ma dernière visite a été
fait il ya un panneau de chantier avec
un drapeau de la république française
bleu blanc rouge bien sûr parce que
c'est tout à fait normal
pas sûr que ce sursaut d'orgueil
national suffisent à reconquérir le
terrain perdu par la france au cameroun
car en attendant les drapeaux français
le drapeau chinois lui flotte bien en
évidence sur le palais des sports de
yaoundé
ce soir soirée de gala des chefs d'état
sous haute sécurité
parce que je vois une quinzaine de
personnalités sont déjà arrivés entrée
uniquement sur carton d'invitation
sauf pour monsieur linh il est ici chez
lui laissez moi vous présenter cet homme
et travail au ministère des sports du
cameroun
c'est lui qui a supervisé mon projet
lui aussi c'est mon grand ami un grand
ami parce que passé le palais des sports
éclairage sono climatisation en
coulisses il s'assure dans la bonne
humeur que la technologie chinoise va
bien fonctionner encore mal fait on note
cravate
je sais je n'arrive pas à rentrer le col
et ça fait plusieurs fois qu'il essaye
et bien moi c'est lui qui me fais mes
notes cravate j'en ai même vu avec des
autruches
ce soir je ne vais pas me j'aurais dû la
mettre
ça aurait fait plus d'africains
à la mauvaise blague dans quelques jours
monsieur dean et son équipe quitteront
définitivement yaoundé le chantier d'une
clinique les attend à douala alors ils
en profitent pour une dernière photo où
on paye encore fermé les yeux
on dirait qu'il dort au moment de
tourner la page
monsieur linh est fier du travail
accompli pour son pays alors vous le
trouvez comment notre stade
c'est mieux que ce que font les français
non entre temps la tribune officielle
s'est remplie michel rocard et alain
juppé ont quitté l'ambassade pour
assister au spectacle de danse africaine
[Musique]
tout fonctionne
monsieur linh peut rentrer à son
campement nous sommes des bâtisseurs
quel que soit le pays
chacune de nos constructions montre ce
dont nous sommes capables et au delà de
tout ça il ya notre patrie la chine
des bâtisseurs des entrepreneurs des
commerçants tous animés du même esprit
de conquête sûr que monsieur yin et les
autres chinois sont venus en afrique
pour longtemps